so what we're going to try to talk about
today is the arithmetic of dynamical
sequences let's do an example so here's
an example maybe you'll recognize let's
let f of X be the function 2x plus 1 and
what I mean by iterating something under
this function is let's start at a point
say x equals 0 when we plug x equals 0
into this function we get 1 and then
let's keep doing that so when we plug 1
into the function we get 2 plus 1 which
is 3 when we plug 3 into the function we
get 6 plus 1 which is 7 so you look at
the last number so 15 31 so maybe I'll
do two more just for a demonstration
here so 62 plus 1 that's 63 and 126 plus
1 it's 127 so this sequence is special
so the sequence you might recognize that
each of these numbers in the sequence
are off from a power of 2 by exactly 1
so this is known as the Mersenne
sequence well people have heard of the
Mersenne sequence because this is a
famous question that we don't know how
to answer is are there infinitely many
prime numbers in this sequence since
this question is so hard one easier
question we could ask would be what are
the prime divisors of each element of
this sequence look like that seems like
a harder question well it might be a
harder question depending on how
specific you want to get but so what I
mean by the prime divisors of elements
of the sequence is we have these factors
so each number factors into prime
numbers as long as we're ignoring 0 here
so 3 is already prime 7 is already prime
but 15 this is 3 times 5
31 that's already prime 63 well let's
see so seven is a prime divisor and 9 is
a divisor but it's not prime it's
actually 3 times 3 times 7 and 127 let's
see I think that's prime and so on
anyway so this is what I mean by prime
divisors and so instead of asking okay
do we have infinitely many elements in
this sequence which are prime we could
at least ask as we go along in the
sequence do we get a new prime at each
step so that's the question I'm
interested
and answering so here okay we don't have
any prime devisers but here three is a
prime divisor that never appeared before
here seven is a prime divisor that never
appeared before here five never appeared
31 never appeared but here we run into a
problem
we broke the streak no new primes is
that bad well depends on what you're
interested in but if the question is do
we always have a new prime divisor for
the Mersenne sequence the answer is no
because look at the sixth element
doesn't have a new prime divisor but the
interesting fact is after that all
Merson numbers have a new prime divisor
every single one every single one what
happened with 63 well it's just when
you're at the beginning of a sequence
the numbers are so close and there's so
many Prime's happening that it can occur
that you sort of fail to have this new
prime divisor and it also matters that
this was the sixth element of the
sequence but that's a little bit
complicated so the point is that after
that after that six element of the
sequence after 63 we always have the new
prime divisors so this is an interesting
thing and I think the next natural
question once you notice that a sequence
like this has some interesting property
is what's special about this sequence
what other sequences have this property
so instead of choosing a function like
2x plus 1 to generate my sequence what
if I chose a nonlinear function so if I
had an x squared in there so let's say I
chose x squared plus 1 but we can still
start generating these sequences so if
we start with 0 if we plug it into this
function is going to map to 1 again but
when we plug one in we get 1 plus 1
which is 2 when we plug 2 in we have 2
squared plus 1 which is 5 we plug 5 in
we have 25 plus 1 which is 26 and when
we plug 26 in I happen to know we end up
with 677 so because I'm dealing with an
x squared instead of an X here the
sequence gets larger much faster but
still
we get the sequence of integers still we
can ask when do we start getting new
prime divisors so if we look at what we
have here so notice again 2 & 5 are
already prime 26 is 2 times 13 and 677
is also prime and it turns out that for
this sequence it's even better than
Merson sequence all numbers after to
have a new prime divisor so this has
proven that after 2 you always get a new
prime divisor in this particular
sequence you showed me an amazing
sequence then you showed me a more
amazing sequence ok well then get ready
so let's do the same thing except that
there's no reason that we're only
talking about positive integers here
right so let's look instead at something
like this and see what happens so again
we start with 0 0 maps to negative 1
negative 1 maps to 1 squared minus 1
which is 0 but we already know where 0
maps 0 maps to negative 1 and so the
sequence we get is completely not
interesting that's cool that's more
interesting well it's definitely not
going to have this property that we have
new prime divisors at least so this is
bad news right as far as this question
is concerned this is a weird sequence so
let's let's try a different negative
number let's try I don't want to try
minus 2 and maybe you can try it and
find out why let's try instead minus 3
all right so let's go so 0 & 0 maps to 0
minus 3 minus 3 maps to 9 minus 3 which
is 6 6 maps to 36 minus 3 3333 maps to
something messy that I don't want to
calculate but now we'll get an infinite
sequence again instead of having this
this repetition like we had in the minus
1 case we'll get an infinite sequence
and again this sequence will have new
prime divisors at each point 0 seconds
every time I'm beginning to think this
is
just special thing anymore I know so let
me tell you you're sort of right so here
I'll write down a general fact if say C
is an integer so a whole number or the
negative of a whole number and C is not
0 minus 1 or minus 2 mostly because we
want to avoid this problem then every
element of the sequence that's generated
from x squared plus C has new prime
divisor so the only exceptions are 0
minus 1 minus 2 this works for X
Squared's but it works for X Squared's
plus an integer if you wanted you could
ask this for a fraction see instead of a
whole number see so if C was 1/2 let's
say so if f of X is x squared plus 1/2
well then what starts happening so 0
maps to 1/2 now the computation is a
little less pleasant but 1/2 is 1/4 plus
1/2 which is 3/4 3/4 when we put it into
this function we have 9 over 16 plus 1/2
which I guess is 17 over 16 does that
sound right and so on so even though
we're getting these fractions in the
sequence the denominators are just
powers of 2 and so when you try and
factor them the only prime that you get
there is 2 so we can still ask the same
question about the numerators in the
sequence so we're just going to we're
just going to ignore them just ignore
the denominators there's not interesting
stuff there happening there anyways so
if you ignore the denominators then we
look and we have this sequence 0 1 3 17
and so on and it turns out that again
you will have this property it seems
sort of fundamental and part of the
reason why is because I've been hiding
an example from you so so maybe one last
example of computation that I'll show
you is this kind of tricky little thing
here x squared minus 7 over 4 so what is
0 map to 0 maps to minus 7 over 4 21
over 16 minus 7 over 16 squared all of a
sudden everything comes to a stop
because look at our numerators 0
seven seven times three so three is a
new prime divisor there but here we
don't have a new prime divisor so
there's something different between 1/2
and minus 7/4 for some reason there's an
element in this sequence where the
numerator doesn't have a new prime
divisor and this is this the only this
is the only number the only fraction
that throws the spinner in the way we
don't know we don't know so just to give
you a hint of why this is true so this
is the only one that we know of but we
don't know if it's the only time it can
possibly happen so what's really going
on behind the scenes here has something
to do with a particular set of numbers
known as the Mandelbrot set which I
won't go into but it's this interesting
fractal where things go kind of crazy
and it's hard to draw a fractal so I'll
just do my best good thank you so let me
put this into perspective for you so
this is a picture of the complex numbers
and I'm interested in the numbers that
are inside of this set and let's look at
the values of C that we've done this
computation for so one we first did x
squared plus one one is over here we
also did minus one minus one is over
here we did minus three which is well
outside of this set we did one half
which is also not inside this set but
minus seven over four it is inside of
this set so minus seven over four it
turns out is right inside this piece of
the Mandelbrot set this lon of the real
of the real numbers there that's it
seems to run right through us way the
fractions that would be is that aren't
there going to be loads of fractions
that are going to cause this problem
then that's a really good point so
you're absolutely right there's there's
tons and tons of fractions on the real
line inside of the Mandelbrot set but
it's not enough it turns out to just be
inside the Mandelbrot set you have to be
particularly very far inside of the
Mandelbrot set and so this is really
saying something special about where the
number C can lie inside of the
Mandelbrot set so if there are other
numbers law
- seven over four that are going to
throw a spanner in our works they
definitely have to be in here that's
right so right away you get for free
that if you take a large enough fraction
say bigger than one for example although
you could get closer for free you get
that there will always be new primes and
those sequences but yeah if we were to
look for other examples of where this
might occur they would have to lie
inside of the Mandelbrot set and they
would have to lie well inside the
Mandelbrot set actually it turns out but
it looks like there are numbers here
that would be pretty well inside the
Mandelbrot set or is it a particular
it's a particular thing inside each of
these bulbs here that I've drawn sort of
half half heartedly there's a special
point and what might happen the only
reason why this might happen is if your
rational number is very very close to
that special point in a technical way
that is is hard to formulate I think it
hard people don't believe that there's
one beyond minus 7 over force if I had
to make a guess I would say probably not
but it would certainly be nice to know
that for sure